いないですがこの中であの家族にがすごい
困っているという人ってください
結構いますねじゃあこの数5位の人を負った感じで肩を揉んでる女くださ
中には痛いとかビターきもツイートか
学べないんいたハーイ気持ちいつもいれば文字しませんが
その感情ちょっと覚えておいてくださいですかはいって言わなくてほしいですよ
この方五位なんですけど色々原因としてはありますか
パソコンの使い過ぎとがあのスマホの見すぎとか
の中にはあの骨盤が曲がっていると化すトレードネックが動画コーナー買って読んな
ことがありますけれども
私は理学療法士です今まで何百人何千人という人を見てきました
その中でも肩こりが酷いっていう人は特に
なんですけどあの病院で七宝もらってもなかなかな女にですねこれがば
あの薬をもらったんだけどもあったんだけども
この xn 青いたくないん
あと改良に声入って行ってもらったんだけども
マッサージでクレクレ言って行ってもらったけども施行気になったまだ凝ってるぞ
もう金を張るし時間も春死どうしてくれるんだろう
そういう話をよく聞きます
実はその方五里の牽引と解決走っていうのは結構簡単なもあったんですね
そう今日をみなさんにあのをシェアしたいと思います
まず何の力説明の仕方なんですけれども
ちょっと難しい専門用語を使ったすずめの仕方と小学生味噌わかるわかる簡単な子を
どっちがいいですか
小学前会い ok ですじゃあこれでいきましょう
じゃあまあ単純に入って
ストレスの原因っていうのはストレスです
ストレスといっても2通りあるんですけれども心体的なストレス
ね
あ
あの病気とか怪我等した気があるなんていうのはもう思い
結構大きいそいつですねあと運動することもストレスだし
運動不足っていうのをストレッチですあるいはがのです今日はフェ多い人は結構
ストレス感じるかも知れませんでもう一つは精神的なストレス精神の的なストレスと
いうのは学校どこ
会社での人間関係彼女とかのなんで色々
子どこだってありますねあと仕事で言うとあの子メティートが学校で試験土間という
プレッシャーが結構ストレスになっています
実際をし動いたって話しているのはもうかなり精神てぃ
侵略的なはそいつが変わっています
今を実力派ウェイは心臓の本でも by 小突いています
手に汗握ってもう口もすごい1本いくんですけど
後だんだん後呼吸の数もモチーフ普段の10倍くらいしてます
永安弾肩も凝ってみました
コレッティのはでもその性質にちゃんと金が対応しますよっていう証拠なんですね
今さっき方ゴリがあるって言ってましたけれども
と人間がそのストレスに対応するためにはどう
時に空気の入れ替えはどんどんどんどんしなきゃない
そういう時に一番手っ取り早いっていうのが形で影響するんですね
例えば電車に乗りたい間に合わない階段男子パーッとしててもうギリギリセーフの移動
意味な飾りいきますよね
お腹に
覚えがありますか
はいでそんな感じでもう空限必要な早く必要だ時も硬い気するんですよ
そうすると
方の風を動かすには方の国がつかありますね
方がに言うと首の筋肉を使って胸を上げて肺を膨らま即死です
だからまあ肩がこるそういうわけです
でもこれ一時的にも終わってよいいんですけどこれが z
継続的にすぐいろんなサービスが毎日毎日来てもういっそ3つも肩で呼吸しているそう
すると体が落ちの体は纐纈時も形でするもんだ
てるな理由で方がどんどん使われてかかる掘っていくと
そういうわけなんです
大丈夫かっ
それで
まあどうねそれでどうすればいいかってストレスをね
取り除こうってまあまあありませんね色々あるんで
じゃあ行きをして息をして方を超えるような税金を止めればいいんじゃないか
名護精神自分それもできません
ではどうすればいいかそれが今明さんに教えたいと思います
じゃあ皆さん語ってください
まあいいですねーをヒョッ積んだがいい
はいそしたらあのね思いっきり深呼吸してくださいアイリスて
はいはいてー
is って負けして
一応すごい止め下さい今交野市どこですか
みんな上がってますね
ストレス感じてるんですか
ig 這い出るワークしなさい
みんな以降あって飾り陰性とも匹も落ちてるんですね
だから次はお腹のを謳歌クマグって言う
そこを使って呼吸をしてみましょうじゃ皆さん
お腹に手を付けて下さい
そしてまずはなくお腹を膨らませながら
鼻から息を吸いますアイスって
お腹を膨らまして吐いてー
で方はしっかりされておいてくださいねなんで花がレディースってこんな高いっぱい
くれます
ね波形
まぁちょっと方が動いてしますねー
愛を中にいっぱい振って
値上げ
お茶なが書いてください
に迎えすって
ますって
はいはい
are you a
いいですねぇ
そしたらさっきまでカテゴリがあるという人待っている
さっきかた後やるといった人てあげてくださいまだこんな感じでまた揉んでみてくださ
どうですか
個人差あると思いますが少しに感じが変わったと思います
相手を下しですよ
その上へ
でもこんな感じやこんな簡単に肩こりが治っていいんですか
横井ジョブですよちゃんと治るんですよじゃあこれを前版
あの朝ファイアー毎晩者にアサルトよる
毎日やってくださいれながらでいいですよあそうですかこれはなかなかあっ粋な工法
ありがとうございましたてい